hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll if
you're like me you know some people
maybe friends or colleagues who believe
untrue things their beliefs are false
incorrect for some reason don't you hate
it when that happens it may even be true
this is a Wilder idea but your friends
might think that you have some untrue
beliefs that's even more annoying why
does this happen why do people believe
different things even when they're quite
educated about them right I mean you
might think that if people just didn't
know that much about something they
might be uncertain in their beliefs and
be corrected when they get more
information but that's not what we see
especially in the social sphere the
political sphere culture War kinds of
questions people believe things despite
the fact that there's a whole bunch of
people who believe other things and are
trying hard to convince them and we have
a special problem these days with the
media landscape with technology we are
flooded with information with opinions
with attempts to change our minds much
more than ever before so there's
actually two questions going on here one
is what is the information or the sets
of claims to which we are being
subjected right are we in filter bubbles
is the news media trying to be accurate
or are we just hearing things that are
tribal or politically slanted in some
way so how do we control the
relationship between our attention and
the information we get and as a society
how should we try to make sure that the
information being given out is
relatively accurate or safe or whatever
you wanted it to be the other question
is then what do we do with that
information that we get what kinds of
information change our minds we like to
imagine a kind of Bayesian Utopia where
we have propositions that we assign
credences to and new evidence comes in
we we update our credences but people
very rarely work that way I mean we've
known that here on mindscape since
episode one our very first episode was
with social psychologist Carol Tavaris
who talks about how people in groups
that have some false belief together can
absolutely maintain that false belief in
the face of enormously strong contrary
evidence so today's conversation is with
Brendan nyhan who is a political
scientist who's done a lot of work on
both sides of this question what is the
kinds of information and influences that
we get and then what do we individually
do with them some of his early work was
on the backfire effect the idea that
under certain circumstances when you
hear evidence that contradicts a belief
that you have you can come away holding
on to that belief even more strongly now
it turns out to nobody's surprise if you
know anything about psychology it's more
nuanced than that that's not always true
it's true in some cases it's not true in
others is an ongoing thing but it's
fascinating how whatever we are as human
beings we are not entirely 100 rational
we have our biases we have our desires
to fit things together you know when I
wrote the big picture I talked about
planets of belief the idea that we have
a particular belief in a particular
proposition independent from everything
else it's just nonsense you know our
beliefs fit together sometimes
coherently and consistently sometimes
less so but that other set of beliefs
that we have everything else that we're
holding on to has an enormous influence
on how we judge each individual thing
that we learn so with Brendan we're
going to talk about the information
sphere that we have out there in the
media right now how well the mainstream
media does in trying to be objective
should it try to be objective when
should it try to call out lies versus
just saying what both sides believe and
then a little bit about how we
individually process that information
and try to personally come up with true
beliefs how do people end up denying
climate change or vaccines or something
like that these are these are questions
that matter right now to the world we
live in and I don't think we got the
once and final answers here but I think
it's something we really need to be
thinking about very carefully so let's
go
[Music]
thank you
Brendan night and welcome to the
mindscape podcast great to be here so I
wanted to start thinking you know about
disinformation misinformation fake news
all these things put us in historical
context because I always worry that we
think we're unique right now but I know
that there was fake news back in the day
there was yellow journalism there was
snake oil salesmen Etc are things really
different right now
well I share that concern that we're too
quick to jump to historical
um uh differences that we think exist at
conspiracy theories or worse and
misinformation is worse and we don't
have any strong scientific bases to draw
those sorts of conclusions
I think it's fair to say that
misinformation and conspiracy theories
have been with us as long as human
beings have existed and if you spend any
time looking at history you'll see
misinformation playing an important role
if you if you look around the world
you'll see the United States is hardly
unique yeah and the role of
misinformation and conspiracy theories
here so
um I'm uh
I'm I would Reserve judgment there are
aspects of how misinformation conspiracy
theories work now that may be different
and it may be particular reason for
concern but the idea that misinformation
and conspiracy theories are more
pervasive now or more widely believed we
just don't know
um One Challenge is of course how you
would measure these these quantities
that was my next question right we only
have modern survey research in the
post-world War II period for the most
part and
the pulling on these questions is
heavily concentrated in the last few
decades and really only the last 10 to
15 for for the most part so we simply
don't have a great deal of empirical
data on belief
similarly uh the way that information
spreads of course differs over time in
ways that are hard to systematically
measure and track
Word of Mouth of course played still
plays an important role but played a
much more important role in Prior errors
and that's not a form of transmission
that's legible to us as Scholars what
gets written down of course is a subset
of what's most important in any time we
now live in this period when Digital
Data are available to us and that allows
for really exciting opportunities to
measure
what's being spread that we might
otherwise not have captured but we
should be important
um you know
um not to what's the expression not to
mistake the map for the terrain right um
what's measurable to us is not
necessarily
um ground truth especially as you move
through different historical eras
there's certainly the technology that
has enabled us to misinform each other
at a remarkable rate right I mean we we
have I I guess back in the day we had
more newspapers pamphlets and things
like that but my guess is it can't
compare to our social media feeds the
number of channels on TV and so forth
yeah I think it's important to remind
people of of all the different kinds of
media we've had and that we've uh you
know newspapers for instance we think of
as a kind of boring
um standardized format uh rarely takes
risks you know Retreat still kind of
both sides journalism and so forth but
prior to the 20th century newspapers
were absolutely wild frequently printing
scurrilous claims about political
opponents heavily partisan
um and so forth they were often a
channel for the worst sorts of uh
information that was being spread
um at the time and the
what we think of now is journalism
essentially didn't exist right the the
profession sort of codifies itself
informally and develops professional
norms and so forth you know in the 20th
century in the early 20th century okay
and prior to that
um you know you could print what you
wanted to print and they were not
necessarily Professional Standards
governing the evidence evidence you had
to Marshall to make those sorts of
claims so that's just one example
um uh you know the list goes on and in
each case this is something important
when these new technologies were became
available people became very concerned
about them and about their harmful
consequences for society and the ways
they could be used to spread
misinformation or to propagandize people
Etc so we've had historically panics
over the written word literally the
printing press on to radio television
and now of course the internet and and
social media again that doesn't mean
there's not reason for concern about our
current
technological configuration but I think
it should make us be a little bit more
circumspect about thinking that what
we're seeing now is going to be the
downfall of democracy because similarly
situated people have come to similar
conclusions about
um prior uh New Media of the time and we
now think of those in a very different
way so future future you know future
Americans future human beings may may
look similarly to us now but it's an
interesting point because if we even
allow ourselves to be open to the idea
that uh different historical eras were
different we tend to think of monotonic
kind of change and and maybe from what
you're saying uh there's a sense in
which it used to be just as sort of
crazy and polarized as it is now and
then there was like a brief interregnum
where the power of the media was
sufficiently concentrated and
regularized and professionalized that
that impression went away and now we're
just returning to that previous state
yeah no I think it's important to uh
make clear to people in the way you're
suggesting just how
uh abnormal historically
um the period around the middle of the
20th century was in the United States in
particular so I'm an American politics
specialist so I'll speak to yeah um the
area that I know best
um historically our politics have been
heavily polarized
um that was true
um prior to this period in the in the
mid 20th century and it's been true
afterwards as we've had this increase in
polarization what's abnormal was this
period that we think of as the way
things were and should be yeah
um which in the in the mid 20th century
um for reasons related to our history
our country's awful history on Race the
parties were not clearly ideologically
divided
and we had due to accidents of the way
technology media technology and
communication worked we had a kind of
establishment consolidation around a
limited set of communication tools we
had newspapers there were economies of
scale that rewarded very large
newspapers and to uh achieve the kind of
readership they needed it to achieve to
um capture those economies of scale uh
they needed very large audiences and so
that meant that the partisan model of
the prior period was supplanted by
um a this kind of neutral journalistic
style that allowed both people from who
supported either party to read the
newspaper so we have these
um consolidation of these very large
newspapers and then we have radio and
television where there's a limited set
of spectrum and
um regulation by the government and
um some informal pressure to maintain
higher new standards and the market
might otherwise support so you have this
unusual media configuration
um where we go from pamphlets and
newspapers lots of kind of chaotic
information landscape to this more
Consolidated establishment media you go
from a wildly partisan National politics
to this less polarized uh one as the
parties become quite divided internally
on the issue of rays and we get this you
know abnormal period in our politics and
many of the norms and institutions that
we think of as foundational to American
democracy
um are really constructions of this
period and what we're struggling with
now is how we create a multi-racial
multi-ethnic democracy when those
conditions no longer apply
um and I just want to be very clear
about the trade-offs here that there's
no uto there's no lost Utopia here sure
it was a very narrow range of voices
that were allowed through the media at
that time
um it was a very narrow set of people
who were represented
um and the reasons that the country
um were you know the country was less
polarized because the parties were
essentially conspiring to keep race off
the national agenda and preserve a
system of racial apartheid yeah in the
South
um to kind of maintain the political and
Civic piece so to speak at the cost of
um the freedom of millions of our fellow
citizens so none of this was acceptable
none of this was sustainable we have to
we're not going the conditions that
generated those Circa chances are are
not coming back and where should they
and and we have to figure out how to
move forward and I I just want to you
know give that brief digression because
I think it's really important sometimes
to avoid the sense of this kind of
golden age Nostalgia that Creeps in when
we think about our politics there are
very significant challenges associated
with polarization and changes in
communication technology but we're not
going to be able to wind back the clock
nor should we and I think that's a
really important starting point for any
conversation about how we move forward
yeah no very much and I think that it's
okay to say look there was something
good about that era and there were also
very bad things about that era and we
can we're big enough to accept both
things at once and now our era has
changed a little bit whether it's cable
TV or the internet and so forth those
economies of scale uh that led to
consolidation are less dramatic I
suppose it's easy for me to just start a
website start a newsletter start a
YouTube video feed or whatever
and we seem to be flooded with
misinformation disinformation fake news
is it worth
distinguishing between misinformation
and disinformation and things like that
well a lot of ink has been spilled on
these questions in in my world of
Scholars who study misinformation I will
say I don't find the distinction
especially helpful most of the time okay
the reason is
um when people construct these
typologies they often just that Define
disinformation as information that is
intentionally that is spread by people
who know it to be false and it's spread
in a malicious manner right we very
rarely have access to people's interior
motives or so-called true beliefs to the
extent those things even exist and so
it's very difficult to pin down when
someone is making a claim they know to
be false right Donald Trump says
literally tens of thousands of false
things how many of them does he believe
to be true I don't know yeah um so
occasionally we can say something you
know like a a Russian disinformation
operation or something where there's a
very well identified wide actor and we
have a kind of ground truth on the
construction of the false information
itself so we know people know that the
claim was uh that the information is
false because they themselves
constructed it but in the absence of
that those unusual circumstances
um I don't find the distinction
especially helpful it often leads to
um debates about motives that aren't
very useful to me right to some extent
whether Donald Trump knows or not that
any given statement he makes is false is
immaterial we should hold them
accountable for being responsible as a
public figure
uh in making accurate statements
everyone misspeaks sometimes I'm sure I
will make errors of fact in this podcast
um but the pattern of
um repeatedly making false statements
doing so after being corrected and doing
you know making these kinds of claims
that are
um Reckless and inflammatory right I
think we can hold him accountable
whether or not he means to do it or not
at some point uh uh a line uh you know
must be drawn and I find it more
important to focus on those kinds of
questions and whether
um you know someone knows a claim to be
true or not and I guess there's a
utopian Vision in which if we have
enough communication channels then you
just can't get away with misinforming
people because some other Communication
channel is going to point out that you
are not telling the truth and that
mechanism seems to be of less strength
or less Effectiveness than maybe we
would hope is that impression off base
no I think we we have to worry a lot
about the incentives right that people
face to make accurate statements uh
especially but not exclusively political
Elites
when you think about the what affects
public opinion when is misinformation
especially harmful
it's often when it comes from people who
have a wide audience and an audience
that's responsive to them
um and political Elites are often among
the most influential figures and
institutions and spreading
misinformation their incentives
unfortunately are quite uh warped
sanctions for making false statements
are quite weak
um uh you know Donald Trump of course is
the canonical example now of
um how little it seems to matter in
terms of the political support UMass if
you make false statements at least under
certain circumstances
um and so
with those incentives in mind of course
the upside to misinformation may be
relatively more attractive right it may
be a way to you know decrease support
for your opponent to make your to
activate your political base to make
your
um uh you know to make a policy debate
tilt in a Direction that's favorable to
you Etc and if the only cost is people
um say you're making false statements in
a in a medium that your supporters don't
trust very much
that's a pretty weak sanction
um now I want to be very clear about
this point and we can talk about it more
because it's a subtle thing I am not
saying we should roll back the First
Amendment sure
um and in fact I'm very uncomfortable
with legal remedies in general
um I think people are have become
um
quite
um uh Reckless and how quickly they jump
to speech suppression as a solution to
this problem and I think they should go
carefully on how those kinds of
steps could be misused
by folks they don't like if they have
control over the relevant institutions
whether it's political
um legal or say control of tech
companies and platforms right
um in all those cases think of who you
don't want controlling speech and now
imagine giving greater control of our
speech
um to that entity right we can all I
think imagine the potential for misuse
um and so I I worry about people who say
well misinformation is a problem and
someone needs to make it go away and the
way to do that are legal restrictions or
the platforms taking care of it or so
forth those are
um uh you know in some cases the
punishment may be you know the the Cure
may be worse than the disease there is a
philosophy question here about the
nature of truth and how possible it is
to get there I forget who it was I read
just very recently some politician
about you know Donald Trump's recent
legal worries uh so Republican
politician was saying that you know this
this assumes that the government can
judge what is the truth
and I'm like well the legal system is
certainly presumed to try to judge what
is the truth but I I think what you're
raising is that if we if we try to make
a law saying you know you can't lie you
can't tell intentionally untrue
statements in the media or whatever that
would be as a practical matter very very
hard to make fair and uh shielded from
misuse
I think that's right um
I tell my students when when I teach
about this topic that at any moment a
philosophy seminar about the nature of
Truth could break out and there are
intense debates in my world about
exactly where we should draw these lines
so for instance for the um the the fact
Checkers you know these predominantly
online
um journalists uh you know who evaluate
the accuracy of statements made by
politicians there's frequently debate
about whether their ratings are are
um fair if they accurately reflect the
evidence if the if the matter at hand is
even a factual question about Truth at
all in some cases it may be subjective
or a matter of opinion in some important
way
um and these are very difficult
questions that um don't necessarily have
um
objective answers and and that's why I
appreciate the way in this country the
bar for defamation and libel cases is
very high right it's very high
um and that prevents cases from being
successfully litigated uh unless
um the claims are abs are extreme
um and
uh
it also you know you can't it's very
difficult to bring cases against public
figures for making false statements I
guess what you know the bottom line to
me is that uh false statements are
um part of living in a Democratic
Society there is no
um and and I'm
concerned about the way we went from
saying misinformation is a problem to
our goal should be to eliminate
misinformation the the price of
eliminating misinformation is no longer
living in a free society and
um we have to accept that there will
always be misinformation with us and
that we have to think about the
competing values at play here that
doesn't mean we shouldn't try to address
misinformation effectively and we can
talk about ways to do that
um but setting up the goal is zero
misinformation is taking us down a road
towards an ill liberal society and this
kind of problem pops up not only with
politicians or Bad actors who want to
misinform for their own reasons but even
with as we hinted at before
journalistic Outlets that are trying to
do their best to be objective right uh
it it can there's certainly a well-known
worry that that degenerates into both
sidesism
um opinions on the shape of the earth
differ so what words of wisdom do you
have for responsible news outlet that is
trying to be objective and stick to the
truth but is so used to just saying well
party I said this and party B said that
that they are reluctant to say and party
B is absolutely lying
yeah I know that this has been a a real
um debate in in journalistic circles now
for um a couple of decades the
fact-checking movement in some ways was
inspired by the failures of mainstream
journalism in this respect
um the the coverage
um originally uh the seeds of this are
the Avalanche movement um where right
um journalists were
um frustrated with the way that the
so-called Willie Horton had was covered
in the news and it seemed to almost
amplify the claims in question rather
than
um providing adequate scrutiny and that
ad watch format is a progenitor to the
fact check format which sought to
reorient the focus of
uh journalism at least within this
framework towards evaluating the
accuracy of the statements made by
politicians instead of reporting what is
quote news which is
um a subjective thing that uh often
leads to that he said she said style of
Journalism you described and in general
I think
um we have seen a kind of transformation
um I would I would point to
um two
um issues that have really uh driven
this change the first is coverage of the
climate movement where it became after
many years of shaming it became
um professionally damaging to both sides
climate change as the evidence became
overwhelming yeah um and and then second
um the sheer volume and Audacity Of
Trump's false statements
um during his campaign and especially
during his time as president when you it
was uh it was simply impossible to
report on Trump and not indicate clearly
that he was making false statements and
both of those I think have
increased the scope of journalists
willingness to describe evidence in
non-50 terms even when contested by the
parties
um you still will see examples where
um uh journalists Retreat to that I
think it's still an ongoing challenge
um but I do think progress has been made
and that's important because you know
Empirical research suggests that when
you get when you're exposed to these
news stories that say you know views on
the shape of the earth differ people
infer
people may infer from that presentation
that experts are divided that the
evidence is mixed
um that there's a lot of uncertainty so
um it's important to
um to communicate precisely the relative
weight of the evidence when such an
expert consensus exists
um you know of course there are dangers
of over correcting in the other
direction too and stating with too much
certainty claims that turn out
um to be poorly supported or wrong we
live through a lot of instances of that
during covid for instance
where the media rushed to State experts
no X you know and then that consensus
would of course be quickly overturned
well that's the problem with science is
that you know we try to be open-minded
to new results coming in and it's hard
to convey that we're pretty confident
that this is true but we will change our
minds if we learn new things but I had
Ezra Klein on the podcast a while ago
talking about polarization and and how
we become more polarized over recent
decades very consistent with things that
that you've said but I I asked the
question and he was sympathetic to the
idea that one thing is just politicians
learn to be better game theorists and
and if you take as your incentive
structure not I want to make the country
a better place but I want to win the
next election then you just act
differently right and and you know maybe
your standards are different and
whatever do you think that the elite
political class has become better at
gaming the system including the fact the
feature of the system that journalists
are trying to be objective
medical scientists so I always think uh
politicians are being strategic and
um
some of the most influential Works in my
field
set you know point out how much of
political Behavior you can explain
simply by the re-election motive yeah
um
at the same time I will say I thought
there were more lines that politicians
wouldn't cross
um then turned out to be the case after
uh during the Trump years and so if
anything I've updated My Views to think
that the re-election motive is
overwhelmingly
um uh shaping politicians uh Behavior I
would have thought actually some of the
policy heterodoxy of trump also would
have constituted a red line for people
who are in politics for ideological or
policy reasons
um but we've seen remarkable flexibility
on some of those issues as well
um so
whether politicians are behaving more
strategically
it's not clear to me um I guess the way
I would describe I think they've always
behaved strategically I guess that what
we've seen that I'm most concerned about
is a breaching of this of of a set of
norms that constrained
um politicians at the national level
from moving into explicitly
anti-democratic explicitly
anti-democratic realm or normalizing
misinformation in the way that Trump did
those two Trends I think
um are genuinely worrisome because when
those kind when that kind of rhetoric
becomes normalized the incentives for
politicians change it was thought it was
career ending to do the kind of kinds of
things that Trump did and so
um for sincere or strategic reasons
politicians didn't do them they may have
believed in the norm and think it
thought it was bad to violate it they
may have just strategically avoided
breaching the norm because they thought
it would be bad for their career but it
you know those um explanations both
generate the same expectation people
won't engage in anti-democratic rhetoric
or anti-democratic actions they won't
spread misinformation as brazenly and at
the volume of trump now we've seen those
norms
be breached and Norms depend on this
shared understanding
of
um the limits of behavior if you cross
some line you will be sanctioned for it
and so a strategic politician May
respond to the breaching of those Norms
by changing their behavior and that's
really what I'm most worried about
we have an ongoing debate about whether
Trump is a kind of one-off figure or a
harbinger of things to come
and
and clearly proven difficult for other
politicians to capture whatever it is
he's doing as we're seeing during the
Republican primary right now so there
are elements of his appeal that clearly
are non-transferable but I think it's
fair to worry that uh the breaching of
those Norms will change the way
politicians approach politics
strategically so let me give you let me
give you a I think a simple example of
this good um Ron DeSantis is running for
president right now it has not gone well
we're recording this on August 23rd
right he um he has struggled he was seen
as a very strong Challenger to Donald
Trump based on his political and policy
success in Florida there was this idea
he could pitch himself as both more
electable and more
um conservative in a conventional sense
and that would be
um you know a combination that could
launch him to
um the presidency
he has struggled he is not
um
attracting nearly as much support
nationally or in key primary States as
expected
um one reason is he has not
found ways to present the case for his
candidacy that are resonating with
primary voters in the Republican Party
and one thing we've seen in recent weeks
is he's been shaking up his campaign
changing staff changing strategy
changing rhetoric is an increasing
um pattern of uh resorting to uh violent
metaphors or indeed the endorsement of
violence itself
so first he talked about uh slitting the
throats of metaphorically of the parts
of the federal government Workforce that
he said he would cut
which is a kind of troubling metaphor
for talking about
um your plans for
um the government civilian Workforce
yeah
um he then has now started talking about
how he will under his administration the
United States will shoot
um alleged drug smugglers at the border
and just kill them
um as they approach or try to cross uh
the border so just to kind of you know
explicit endorsement of extrajudicial
violence right so that's per se and
Ronda Santos is nothing if not strategic
he's a very cerebral person he is
responding to the incentives he faced
his kind of wonky
um style I will you know stand up to the
woke people for you Etc was not
resonating and now he starts talking
about violence and boy he's getting a
response this is one of the this is
becoming one of the lines that's
generating the strongest responses at
his rallies he may deploy it at the
Republican presidential debate that's
going to take place tonight
um and that's exactly the kind of thing
I'm worried about that
um strategic politicians responding to
these incentives may take us towards
increasingly
um authoritarian and illiberal places if
we're not uh careful because even if you
just want to hold uh you know win and
hold office that may be the path
um to do so unfortunately in the current
Republican party especially
well and there's a feedback loop with
the specifics of our political system
right you know in your political
scientists you know about the median
voter theorem there's this happy idea
that politicians will move to the center
to grab the largest number of votes but
when we are in such a polarized uh
atmosphere especially with such strong
Geographic polarization uh as long as
you think that you know your parties has
a good chance of winning most of the
electoral votes or motorists most of the
state houses or Etc you're you're just
appealing to the party and you're just
appealing to you know get people out to
vote by kind of poking at their emotions
and getting them uh you know very
fervent and so forth so these are not I
don't know if this is temporary or or if
it's a a just a insight into how things
work that we're politicians seem to be
moving towards Extreme Measures to game
again game the system but in this case
not the uh media system but the
particular electoral system we have here
in the U.S
yeah I think political scientists are
increasingly
um troubled by the intersection of
geographic polarization and our
two-party system the incentives to try
to uh appeal to wider audiences are are
um quite limited most members of
Congress
um are at greater risk of losing a
primer than they are of losing a general
election yeah and under those
circumstances it's not surprising
although extremely disappointing
um that so many Republicans would not
vote to disqualify Donald Trump for
running for from uh running for office
again after the January 6 Insurrection
um if they had taken that step we
wouldn't be in the position we are today
but given the Electoral incentives they
face of course
um that may be an entirely rational
strategic response
um uh similarly at the national level
um we're so closely divided
um and that uh the downside
to taking
extreme or anti-democratic actions is
relatively limited for all the things
that Donald Trump did his of his
approval rating moved in a very narrow
base so many so many Americans were
locked into how they felt about him Pro
income and we've seen the same pattern
under Joe Biden that is not a specific
that is not specific to Trump
um the uh the two-party uh system with
levels of polarization we've seen now
has created
um you know a a circumstance where
there's not much downside risk your
supporters will stick with you almost no
matter what and it's very difficult to
win over the other side
um if you look historically in that
unusual mid 20th century period we were
describing earlier you'll see Wild
variations and approval ratings that
we've we have not seen
um now in many years uh the last time we
saw it was after September 11th
um and ever since we've been in the The
Presence have been approval rings have
been moving in these very very narrow
bands
um one other point I would make is just
simply that the two-party system itself
has has a dangerous sort of zero-sum
logic to it
um anything I do that helps the other
side automatically hurts mine
um and that's why I think we're seeing
more political scientists who are open
to changes in the American system to
move towards multi-party
um governance it would change the
zero-sum logic that would create a way
for Republicans who are uncomfortable
with the misinformation and
anti-democratic tilt of trump and his
accolades to uh have a viable path
forward uh electorally right a world
where there's a center right party as
well as a far a party
um would provide a home and and a
potentially sustainable path towards
electoral security for the the Mitt
Romney's of the world and the George W
bushes and John McCain's and you know
that whole
um uh swath of the Republican party
right now our electoral institutions
make it very difficult
um for those people we're seeing many of
them retiring and seeding the field to
uh Stronger supporters of trump and
that's going to be a challenge for the
Republican party going forward again
just due to the Strategic Behavior
people respond to the incentives they
face
let's move on a little bit from the
elite politicians here because they're
not the only issue we have
Facebook and the social media algorithms
and so forth that have absolutely
contributed to the spreading of dis and
Miss info
um I I guess I can ask an analogous
question there is that maliciousness or
people just you know people or the
companies running these platforms just
doing what they think is best and
there's sort of a inevitable spiral that
we're in
yeah that's a tricky question you know
the platforms are very different
especially in a world where Elon Musk
controls Twitter
um
speaking about Twitter and Facebook and
the pre-musk era though
I think it's fair to say that the
platforms were trying to do their best
and in general
um
there were at least people within the
companies who are working very hard to
try to address concerns about the spread
of misinformation on the platform
it turns out to be very difficult to
identify and effectively counter uh
misinformation
um on platforms you really have to think
about the kinds of trade-offs we
described earlier
um the interventions there have been
misguided interventions
um in terms of limiting the spread for
instance of information about Hunter
Biden's laptop
or various claims about covid that
turned out to be true that I think don't
look very good in retrospect and we
should bear that in mind when we when we
think about the platforms intervening
more aggressively at the same time there
are lots of there there are many cases
where the platforms were
negligent in addressing potential
vectors of harm on the platforms that
yeah you know we talked at the beginning
about why now might not be unique but it
is of course true that the platforms
enable
false information to spread fast faster
than it ever has before and
um that can be uh
quite powerful
um you know when something really
spreads in that Viral manner
um that can enable false information to
reach people very rapidly it can also
serve as false claims
um from the kind of digital Grassroots
that are then popularized and spread
um by
prominent news outlets and political
figures
I've we all we all hear about the fact
the idea that people now have filters
and they live in bubbles because they
can pick and choose their own news
sources but I've recently read claims to
the effect that
it's not true that we live in filters uh
it's just or we live in bubbles it's
just true that we are very good at
ignoring the the news we do want to
ignore and and so we sort of effectively
filter out ourselves no matter what the
world is giving us
yeah I've been
a claims that we um that Echo Chambers
are predominant you hear these claims
about Echo Chambers and filter Bubbles
and so forth and the the worry is that
digital media make it especially the
intersection of digital media and
particularly social media
um and polarization have created
um a circumstance where people are
predominantly living in Echo Chambers or
filter bubbles right um the empirical
data we have uh which is uh unusually
rich now because of
um the kinds of digital Behavior data
that can now be collected shows that
um those sorts of claims are not uh well
supported
um most people's information diet is
relatively balanced
on social media people are often
encountering information they don't like
um relative to for instance the
political mix in the area you live or
the friends and family you have
um you're probably encountering much
more discordant information online
um to make this more precise you know
I've conducted uh I conducted a study
after the 2016 election when there was
this the the panic over fake news and we
found that the untrustworthy websites
which are a particular form of
potentially harmful content people were
worried about that people thought were
creating these kinds of echo chamber
effects those were
heavily consumption of those websites
was heavily concentrated among a small
uh portion of the population something
like
um
20 percent of the uh of Americans that
twenty percent of Americans are the most
conservative information diets online
we're responsible for about 60 of the
exposure to those sites in our data
we've seen even more extreme estimates
for exposure to Russian misinformation
content during the 2016 election
um exposure to so-called fake news on
Twitter those were again concentrated
among very small subsets of the public
um we recently did a study of YouTube
exposure to the potential the most
worrisome channels on YouTube again
overwhelmingly concentrated in a very
small uh percentage of the public so in
General Echo chamber claims are
overstated
um in particular exposure to these kinds
of potentially harmful content seems to
be concentrated to this
um narrow subsets of people who already
have quite strong or extreme views so I
think that worry is misplaced we should
think instead about
um how uh exposure to this kind of
content might generate important Harms
in the world even when it's being
um uh done by a small minority right so
you might think of
things like January 6 for instance right
the ways that digital technology helps
enable the mobilization of people yeah
who already have extreme refringe views
um That's the Way digital technology
might Inspire acts of violence in the
real world or
um racial or ethnic hate things like
that that translate the kind of latent
sentiments that are out there
um in the world in these extreme pockets
of the population and help them manifest
in harmful ways in the world I'm more
worried about that than I am about the
average person being trapped in Echo
chamber filter bubble the average
American has better things to do to be
perfectly honest with you they are not
spending hours and hours in
um so-called rabbit holes or reading
tons and tons of politics they don't
follow politics that closely even again
that doesn't mean there aren't reasons
for concern about digital media there
are we should be really precise about it
and this these kinds of lose claims
based on anecdotes I think have led us
down uh the wrong road
um in thinking about all the platforms
and the kinds of harms that they could
generate and it brings up the
complicated issue of how people actually
form their beliefs uh it's certainly not
true they're just exposed to claims and
believe them it's not even true that
they are good bayesians and have priors
and update things right I mean the how
do we judge the relationship between
what people are hearing and what they're
choosing to accept
yeah this is an area of ongoing research
and I think
um what we're tending to see
um the emerging story from the research
suggests that when you expose people to
corrective information directly people
will tend to update their views at least
in part in the direction of the
information that they're exposed to even
if it's counterattitudinal
um and
that's a kind of encouraging finding
um that perhaps discouraging finding
depending on your point of view is that
those effects may not be durable and
they may not lead to the changes in
attitudes or behavior that people expect
right often there's an implicit model
people have in their head that
um as human beings we reason from Facts
to opinions or attitudes and to behavior
right we learn things about candidates
we have factual understanding of the
validity of their statements then we
update our opinion about that candidate
and we decide whether to vote for them
we learn things about covid then we have
opinions about covid policy then we go
decide if we're going to get a vaccine
or not but
it turns out the direction of causality
is not necessarily clear in many cases
our factual beliefs may be reflections
of the opinions we hold or the behaviors
we choose to engage in
um they it may also be the case that
there are a number of reasons we hold
those opinions or engage in those
behaviors and changing our factual
beliefs may not necessarily have any
effect at all and so we'll often see
cases where people say yeah I understand
Trump didn't make that claim uh you're
sorry Trump made a claim that was false
I accept that claim was false doesn't
change how I feel about it don't care
yeah
um this false claim about uh covet Okay
I accept that as false but I'm not going
to change how I feel about covid policy
about whether I should get a vaccine and
um you know and importantly you know
this goes back to your point about uh
philosophy earlier it's not necessarily
the case that you have to that it's
logic entailed that you must change your
opinion or behavior because of that
particular fact right you you as an
observer may have a particular belief
system where you think one should make
that
um you know update their opinion or or
change their behavior in that way but of
course it's not necessarily
um so it just it simply depends on um
how you weight the relevant
considerations which of course is
subjective now I think this is a great
point I think that people are a little
bit too quick to attribute to
irrationality that which is better
explained just by you know trying to
make sure everything you know kind of
fits together in some way when it comes
to teaching physics classes or giving
public talks about physics uh you know
people ask me how to do it my first
thing is don't imagine that your
audience are empty vessels into which
you are pouring your wisdom and to me it
might make perfect sense that someone
discounts a certain fact even though
they think the fact is true because
there's a whole bunch of other things
that they believe that are gonna Still
Point them in another Direction
I think that's right
um people
um have reasons for what they do it may
not be at the ones that you would uh
like them to have but
um it's it's it's not simply a mat right
so I think that the mistake is thinking
if we pour accurate factual information
into people they will come out with the
opinions and behaviors you would like
yeah and that that just rarely turns out
to be the case in any of the areas I
study and you know look we all do it
there's left-wing conspiracy theories as
right-wing conspiracy theories Etc is
anything from your research giving you a
little bit of insight into how we
personally can you know sweep our own
doorsteps and and try to do better at
separating the true news from the fake
news
you know I wish I had a silver bullet
and um and I don't and you know if
anything
the emphasis that I tend to recommend is
on Elites and institutions because human
nature is what it is and it's not going
to change except in evolutionary time so
uh faulting people for being human
beings
to me
um often leads us down a road um that
generates a kind of elitism and
condescension I don't like in these
conversations I think people are being
failed by the elite State Trust they're
being failed by the institutions that
fail
um to give them the information they
need to form more accurate beliefs and
so we should challenge the media to do
better we should challenge politicians
to make accurate statements and so forth
with that said what you can do
um you know trying to rely on
trustworthy sources of news and
information of course will improve the
likelihood that you're exposed to
accurate information they won't get
everything right but on average they
will do better
um it's also the case actually a finding
that comes out of recent research that I
think is useful is
um that it's important to take accuracy
into consideration when you're
um interacting with news and information
online
um there's a stream of research that
basically finds that just prompting
people to keep accuracy in mind before
they encounter
um
social media content
seems to help them
um make judgments that better reflect
the accuracy of what they're interacting
with because it turns out
there are lots of reasons we decide what
to share and what not to share and
accuracy is only one of them so simply
slowing down
and thinking about is this accurate or
not in the moment
you know is a small but useful thing you
can do that will help you do better now
um I'm not sure how scalable that is if
every time you went on social media they
said accuracy accuracy accuracy
eventually you tune them out the way you
do any of those kind of repeated
reminders
um but on the margin it's a nice it's a
nice uh thing to do
um there are also some um pretty useful
uh tips for Discerning accurate
information online that are sometimes
distributed I've tested the ones that
Facebook rolled out after 2016 and they
were surprisingly effective just hear a
set of simple rules you might keep in
mind right when you encounter a news
headline is this true does it seem too
good to be true are they using emotional
language in a way that's designed
potentially designed to inflame me is
this you know what's the source of this
information just a series of simple
questions like that you might ask about
the information you come across seems to
help people do a bit better and
Discerning what information is valid and
what information is invalid it also
seems to me that since we are very
polarized these days and people just
perceive the other side as the enemy no
matter which side they're on they're
we're a little too quick to pick up
claims and purported news stories that
make us feel good or make the other side
look bad right I mean some kind of that
you already mentioned it's too good to
be true but you know just thinking well
I like this it makes me feel Superior I
want it to be true that's something that
we should be more skeptical about rather
than less
absolutely right if you can if you if if
we're at to extend that we're able to
reflect our own biases which I think is
a challenge for every person
um if this is something that you realize
you might be gravitating towards for
those reasons and taking a second look
might be important and I'll give you an
example of a design feature on a
platform that I I think tries to address
us in a useful way
um I think this was undone by musk but
earlier on Twitter when you try to
retweet an article with a link and you
hadn't clicked on the link right Twitter
would ask you hey do you want to read
that story first and my suspicion is
that in many cases people were hammering
that link without even reading the story
when it was consistent with their prior
beliefs yeah when I was consistent with
their understanding of who the good guys
and bad guys were and who's right and
who's wrong and so forth
um if you ever for those of you who have
a Twitter account you can look at your
own analytics data and see people almost
never click the link yeah and so I worry
that we're jumping to the kinds of
conclusions you're describing and using
those button those retweet and share
buttons as an expression of affiliation
um with a side or an idea and that's
where I think we can easily go Australia
okay I know you have a deadline so the
last question will be a quick and easy
one how would you fix democracy
or I mean you already mentioned the idea
that political scientists are playing
with ways to make it easier to be
centrists less extreme Etc or I don't
know whether you care about voting
systems and things like that I mean is
it time for big structural changes in
how we elect our leadership
uh I'm ready to consider them and I
wasn't I wasn't there a few years ago um
I'll recommend to your listeners uh lee
drutman's work in this area he has a
book called
um uh breaking the two-party Doom Loop
that I think is a really nice
introduction to uh why we should
reconsider the two-party system and how
we can start to do so he's continuing to
work in this area
um if you if you're able to find his
work at the new America Foundation
um he's really at The Cutting Edge
people are experimenting with lots of
different potential changes the one
that's gotten the most interest is
ranked Choice voting I don't think that
will be enough
um but I just want to go back to the
kind of the two big Ideas we've we've
talked about when you get out of a
two-party framework
um it gets us out of that binary
zero-sum thinking that I think can
contribute both to the endorsement of
anti-democratic statements and actions
and also creates conditions that are
ripe for the spread of misinformation
right when you're in a good a good guy
bad guy framework
um your side is right and the other side
is wrong
um multi-party systems have their
challenges but there's a reason that um
we are
um quite unusual among our peers in our
system of government and I think it's
it's it's time to restructure how we do
things how we get there is a very
difficult challenge given the nature of
the Constitution but that is a topic for
another podcast so thank you for having
me yeah I do I do worry that when we
start changing the Constitution things
will get worse so that there's a certain
conservatism there that makes sense to
me but uh thanks very much has given us
a lot to think about Brendan nightan
thanks for being on the mindscape
podcast
my pleasure
[Music]